olá a todos que sua alma que fala e
rodar que seja muito bem vindo
jamais um vídeo e os tragos de que mais
um episódio da nossa épica série the
fight night at freddy's e hoje esta
falha pessoal por isso vão jogar é sexta
à noite que foi a noite bônus com o jogo
nos deu não é
eu espero que esta noite não seja mais
complicada do que a quinta
como vocês sabem eu joguei uma hora e
meia para passar a quinta noite por isso
espero mesmo que esta não seja assim tão
difícil que seja uma coisa mais bônus
mais fácil não é
ok pessoal meia noite nada deus não está
aqui o pátio para que eu fique em cima
dos meu padim tal em cima mas está
tranquilão só precisamos ficar aqui está
tranquilo cofres outro curioso
estou tranquilo caraça gmail noite um
jantar lineu sua loja e esta noite vai
ser mais difícil vai vai vai ser se
senhora mas esse sim é a taça rio já
empatava e jack white também já que
ocorre uma da manhã pessoal uma da manhã
quente a canção como esta manhã que a
maneira como causando um cujas foram
embora mas só quem já se foi embora
deixando sólidos a raposa só quem está
lá dentro ainda a porta é pagar as luzes
vai ganhar um livro em casa caiada
brincar com qualquer coisa está fechado
mas acho que é mesmo muito rápido só
muito rápido mesmo por não estarmos
bateria uma da manhã e 75% eu acho que é
bom eu acho que é bom eu acho que sim
acho que o bahia bater e
e é ele já é parecem mais que se dar por
que é que tu quentes por terem medo
[ __ ]
tenho medo que o atendimento começa a
cantar num buraco é que o total até
mesmo um toque francês muito feliz não
diz francis não há indicação da canção
da questão da raposa itália entrou
canais ok pessoal você já que
recomendaram para não abrir a câmera
porque não vai gostar quando algo não
funciona para não abrir a câmera então
não vou abrir a câmera e nobreak câmera
mas não vai mostrar a mesma possa ser um
trabalho meu você chão trabalho obriga a
câmara a se abrir e nós estaremos aí
você se não conseguir fazer nada ou por
ser a mesma possa ser um trabalho eu
posso e chan mymag agora o que eu faço
agora agora o que eu faço não consegui
fazer nada
já a porta nada por isso as câmeras nada
nosso tempo está a passar algum tempo
está a passar e tudo fica assim testes
da manhã a deus não percebem tudo pronto
eu não vou abrir a câmera pessoal vocês
disseram pra quando as luzes não
funcionar em pleno o abrir e câmera
então é isso que vai fazer novo
brincando vou ficar quieto o tempo vai
passar
só espero que não pareça a china também
a nova e eu não pareço só vejo que há
muito tempo à espera de erros não parece
ser mesmo o país parece estar a resultar
se conseguiria até às seis da manhã só
por ficar aqui à espera e é ótimo
ok
quando alguém estiver à espera ou mal
percebeu
eu sei disso eu sei disso corpos no
fashion rio foi obrigada a abrir a
câmera
deixamos de ouvir só que o tempo passa
para às 3 da manhã se não passar eu sou
obrigado a abrir a câmera ela tempo
passa e ainda manuela das três da manhã
sabe que o senhor não da pessoa não dá
nem pra entrar com qualquer coisa certa
pois a agenda tal e lembro que o coelho
o coi não o sá pinto amarela e brincar
com os pratos ali na zona das pizzas e
os raposas já no segundo a equipe da
casa eu nunca tinha aparecido assim não
comento quer desculpas à tua espera ter
estilo é do diabo meu estilo é do diabo
eu sou o pai natal lei
raposo também jacilda curtindo jato foi
time foram buscar sol é fechar até já
levou memória e vou baixar a câmera já
tenho
não assusta mais seco e menos
e bem pessoal eu já tô aqui há muito
tempo mesmo consegue outra vez por
morrer entretanto e o máximo que eu
consigo ir pessoal e até às quatro da
manhã eu não conseguir muito mais do que
quatro da manhã eu não saiba a autoria
das câmeras muito rápido muito tempo as
luzes e mesmo assim eles conseguem
apanhar eu não sei que eu tenho que
fazer só 78 diz é difícil então esta
sexta é super extreme uma arte fere
difícil meu é muito difícil viram já 222
funk bichos na minha porta milton e ao
mesmo tempo eu não sou eu sim o estudo
moneo toque a uma faca embora a escala
desta porcaria e mesmo assim ganhou as
páginas viram só viram indo agora
preciso bater apareceu outra vez é sério
não perdoou o pessoal está muito
complicado tá muito complicado no
coração não aguenta mas eu vou conseguir
um erro conseguia nem ficar aqui o dia
todo
nem com vida e sai à meia noite eu vou
conseguir ficar até a sétima noite só de
juros
ok ok sarney pato e tempo meu eu pude
filho também filho da mãe nem filho nem
josé raposas que não tem um biótipo de
um coronel cápsulas e já não sei o que
fazer eu já to que há muito tempo desta
porcaria e é o coelho eu quando eu penso
que ele não faz mal ou é o coelho quando
eu penso que vai mostrar se a raposa
aparece o pato duas foi quem fez
seguidas meu eu já não sei meu eu já não
sei como é que eu ia passar estou na ite
e nem mais de 6.000 eu tenho passará
foquinho cury da noite site chá
começasse um jogo aí pessoal porque a
sério este jogo é muito muito complicado
você está em ter uma coordenação chu
entre que é uma coisa que eu não tenho
mas que estou a treinar com este show
que é parte ou não é
mas vocês tentaram ver muita coisa ao
mesmo tempo escapa um pequeno detalhe
parece os bichos não é josé pinto
amarelo tridente monex assim um em
quinto com dentro um pacto com dente o
mec já se viu isto
e agora
agora respiram é meia noite nem passar
um 20 segundo lugar já parece meu lugar
aparece aqui uns do do zé pinto
ali o pato até às vezes abre a câmera
pessoal a serem tantas vezes que eu to
kiss guarujá para a câmara por instinto
já não é porque quer ir à câmara porque
o meu dedo passa lá sozinho o meu
cérebro já está automático eu já vi diz
coisas automaticamente só seria o jato
que há muito funk em tempo tentará o
estudo ao mesmo tempo muita coisa aqui
muita coisa que se passa a ok
há uma cama e não vindo a ser capa de
cada um de nós está fechado ali dentro
que o seu puxa o saco olhos é pato é
para vocês devem seguir 10 mil watts
vence pois pasmem
você venceu o suporte os 10 seus fiéis é
um quinto é comer um coelho é o
espetáculo vocês deviam ter vergonha
nessa cara é o kit vergonha
o preço do shopping como mentolado um ao
outro do outro o preço de capa e impondo
se à luz cheio meu filhos da mãe filhos
da mãe já apanharam eu vou fechar essa
porta já apanharam não dá nenhum fez
isto porque o lixo
filha de um corno da porta com um
fantoche
agora vou ver quebra e que vai perceber
pinto meu sempre aparece quase pintar eu
não gostar mas claro tinha que vir josé
pinto amarelo só assim o steel está
muito bem foi de 100 senhora mas está
muito arcor meu quem é que vai conseguir
passar isso e hoje pessoal mais uma vez
um vídeo vai ser um pouquinho tarde
porque porque estou jogar muito porque
eu estou a jogar muito porque o jogo é
difícil uma porca é é difícil ter uma
porca e por isso tentará que quatro
horas mas eu vou chegar ao fim eu já
disse sou nem com vida e sai amanhã à
noite eu vou colocar hoje um vídeo ela
viaja terça-feira à meia-noite é bom
porque à noite só começará amanhã à
noite e terminou a prova em hockenheim
mas pronto sol nem que o punho um vídeo
muito tarde o púcaro vídeo pouco cara e
vou conseguir passar a sexta noite
porque o que é jogar a sétima jogar
aceito e se é pra fazer uma série pra
acabar e pra cravar a série para gravar
a série só agora é agora que vamos
conseguir
fala sério deixe a nossa força deixa um
gosto like favorito para me ajudarem
conseguir escapar deixa zé manés meu
time está aqui e voltei para cá
ok
ah não eu fechei a porta sendo um corpo
não pode ser é um eficiente a porta eu
não venham com essas coisas agora não
venham com isso mesmo agora aporta
pessoal vocês viram eu puxei para
terminar a última da hora ea máquina
painel
por favor diga nunca passei por favor
por favor por favor eu também só do
primeiro trimestre também muito digamos
que eu pensei 'por favor' ativa que
horas horas os garis por favor meu tudo
isso pra não sair do jogo eu passei não
poderia pessoal seria ativa que há muito
tempo meu ok estamos mais outro cheque
de 120 dólares tudo bem não quer saber
do dinheiro pra nada
sua série no tive que muito muito muito
tempo eu não sei acho que vão pra umas
quatro ou cinco horas jogar esta
porcaria e finalmente consegui chegar ao
fim de sua fala sério e gastar na nossa
casa night
você já ouviu falar nesta canção night e
eu vou jogar lá pessoal mais a sério por
favor deixem voz forte apoio pessoal que
ver que muitas horas hoje a julgar esta
porcaria para conseguir passar dessa
está noite pessoal a sério eu já não sei
se fico contente que ele vive avanços
ainda fico com mais pressão por jogar
mais uma questão night
eu nem sei como é que esta noite mas
vamos lá então ver o cap só gastam night
nós temos aqui os vários bichos do jogo
que é o fred o boni albany boni a chica
e um fox e ética ética e bancos só nós
aqui podemos configurar então quantos
cremos
é assim assim tal embora já tonto dia 21
só levamos só então experimentar a nossa
questão night contudo os monstros e 20 e
agora lá então uma cápsula seja estou
muito contente por ter passado esta
noite meu muito mesmo
o tj ficar tarde eu acho que já vou
falar muito alto nos pronto o kit só
agora lá salvar o e atenção pessoal não
tenciona passar esta casa na estréia ao
prever o quão difícil pode ser todos os
bichos nível 20
por isso não conta que o pastor noite
não não na nota então é isso pessoal nós
vamos ficar por aqui com esta épica
série faz night é fredes chegamos
finalmente ao fim e não vou pensar que
os terminais porque não vale a pena
pessoal e eu nem consigo porque o máximo
de 21.000 silva até sexta à noite tive é
que horas
imaginem os caras que estão no haiti com
tudo ao máximo é completamente
impossível é para malucos por isso é
isso pessoal deixe eu posso porta do epr
esta série e amanhã vai ser um vídeo
especial ainda pessoal sobre esta seria
então não percam só a minha passagem
pelo canal ainda ter mais um vídeo
especial do fight night at freddy's
deixou nosso povo fique bem ea prova